but i wanna i wanna i wanna pull up this
tweet from brett weinstein and get into
this and we'll talk about this divide
brett weinstein tweeted in response to a
tweet from don winslow
who says new video trump's new army
volume up
on january 20th donald trump will no
longer be the commander-in-chief
he will lose control of the u.s armed
forces and take control of a new army
brett weinstein says this video is
diabolical painting millions of citizens
not only as dis disloyal to the nation
but as literal terrorists as it attempts
to draft the rest into
fighting their neighbors in a civil war
the filmmakers clearly desire
i stand with all patriots against this
madness
and so we have this uh this is the tweet
from brett and then uh it was a
different tweet so
this is the video he posted and uh uh i
don't wanna i'm not gonna play through
the whole thing because i think it's
it's disturbing and it's quite long
but it shows regular people at a trump
rally
and says this army it's just people who
showed up this is people waving american
flags
what they don't realize or what what i
think they don't care
about is that at dc you had
hundreds of thousands of people cheering
for the president as he gave one of his
last big public events
then you had a few thousand march on the
capitol grounds
and a few hundred went inside those
people are all being arrested
it was a stupid thing to do they
shouldn't have done it they're gonna
arrested for it well so be it
but the overwhelming majority hundreds
of thousands of people
didn't do or say anything to anybody
they showed up there was one guy who
lost his uh
record label buddha was his name ariel
pink ariel pink
because he was just there and he said i
went saw the speech and i went went back
home there's a a an intelligence
a psychological operations officer being
investigated
for simply bringing people to see the
president speak and then going back to
hotel
that's how like insane things are
getting
and so i know they'll say i'm biased
and they like to uh you know assign your
your
whether you're left or right not based
on what you believe but based on who you
defend i guess
but when you have a dude coming out
putting a video up
encouraging civil war and telling people
to fight their neighbors
that's not coming from the right the
right is the
the worst of the worst conspiracies we
get from the right are pointed at global
elites
bankers politicians the left is
targeting working class people
regular americans walking around on the
ground that's why you know i
i talk about this we talk about civil
war
i'm not saying it's a good thing i'm
saying it's a bad thing and i'm saying
so long as these people keep advocating
for things like this and putting these
videos out
they're not getting banned when they do
this it is people like brett weinstein
who had unity party
trying to bring people together nope
banned it's conservative banned unity
got banned yep how did why did it get
banned no idea no one knows
are you familiar with the unity party so
brett weinstein is a
professor he's a smart fellow and he
wanted to get a left uh left-wing
individual and a right-wing individual
and have them run on the same ticket
to unify as much of the left and the
right as possible to stop this divide
and social media nuked his campaign just
outright removed it
yeah we're in a toxic environment and
that's not going away anytime soon you
know i talked about the five percent but
that was of the day
you know as we we daily update so so do
you mean like a five percent chance is
that what that means right that
in the sense of even what what would
happen tomorrow so
we're we're not activated right we don't
believe it's going that's kind of high
it is yeah was it one in 20. so you have
it's the reasons it's the cascading
effects behind all this
it's never just one thing it's how this
continues to build
and you know i don't know how small or
if there will be a honeymoon period for
the incoming uh administration but
wherever luke and i are about to take it
no no no
i doubt it too because of this toxic
situation and we're going to
so many precedences have been stomped
upon
that there's no end in sight let me ask
you the tough question
what if you have members who are
staunchly anti-trump
i mean you don't screen people's
politics when they no no we don't
what happens if you've got people who
are you know come in there saying donald
trump's destroyed this country
the conflict is all his fault and then
they show up one day and there's another
guy who says
biden destroyed this country it's all
the democrats fault and they walk up to
each other guys got a gadsden flag in
america the other guy's wearing biden or
whatever
well if we have to come together those
things don't matter anymore
yeah because things fell apart and then
people will
get perspective i think that's actually
the
you know one thing we mentioned before
we talked about before we started the
show you mentioned these
silos where millionaires will get
bunkers and stuff i think
actually one thing that makes what you
guys do what makes it work more than
anything else is
you have leadership you have people like
you who are running it who
will be the ones to intervene and say
shut your mouth if you want to survive
stop fighting over this stuff
absolutely and and see that's that's
really the only way it will work
because you know people try to do this
either on their own or they try to do it
in smaller groups
but it generally ends in confrontation
either financially
or over how all this is going to work
and then they'll reach out and contact
us and say do you want to purchase this
land and stuff because
we you know we no longer can do this we
get that all the time
because without structure it's not going
to work
you're talking about people coming under
an extremely stressful situation
and if if there isn't something already
in place
it'll be chaos now um before you made a
very good point you're
saying that people just need to take a
step back i mean that's something me and
you have been talking about for years
like calm down relax take a step back
stop escalating these things stop the
cycle of hate
uh that that's been perpetrated by the
mainstream media but it looks like we're
definitely full steam ahead
on the divide and conquer train and
there's no stopping it
how bad if it would get really bad do
you see it getting because
as you said it's a slippery slope we've
been seeing it for a while but the
snowball that started
it's already getting pretty big what
would be the worst
possible scenario that you would see
unfolding from here
well we're i think again in order to get
attention for an incoming administration
we're going to see an uptick in some
kind of unrest those looking to
get the attention on to them so that
then they can promote
whatever it is they're looking to
promote so then that is going to upset
those who are against whatever they are
promoting and so we're not going to see
a low
we'll see a consistent rebutting of
heads
and then it really depends on what the
local governments do so much of this
depends on what the politicians do
in order to make this go away to a
certain degree and calm it down or not
so you had the the chop chats thing
which you guys i'm sure
talked about oh you know yeah so many
times but
so when that leader comes out and says
the summer of love
and she probably believed it i mean
i have no idea right that was her
perspective at the time or was just
something to be said politically
but then it completely collapses and it
it shows you
what's going on now i know that's been
tried you know in a couple different
places in some other ways
but law enforcement already cut that off
they've seen it so um
so we won't necessarily see the same
things it's the one you don't see
coming and that's what we're going to
you know you you gotta they'll have to
be on guard for but
there'll be things that will take us by
surprise these people uh
these people who are advocating for
conflict i don't care which faction
what your ideology is left right
whatever many of them actually now
i think it's fair to say more so on the
left than the right they have no idea
what they're asking for
i think with with conservatives you're
more likely to find people who
live in rural areas who have fired guns
and who understand
conflict and these threats not
completely but
definitely more so than the left uh so i
guess
i don't want to you know um maybe make
an issue of it for you guys but if you
can't answer
do you tend to see more conservatives
than liberals
i would i mean i say it would be fair
from what you know
those who i know and when groups have
come out i would say definitely
you you can say that it leans that way
but
it's not a big part of even their
mentality when they come out
they're trying to get away from that you
understand that that's
uh they want to escape all of
this butting of heads and all the
rhetoric and
and all the you know insidious talk you
know
towards one you know partisan political
politics is insane but it's but it's
tribal now it's beyond parties
like when you when you have two parties
you're like your party is wrong now it's
tribe it's like you're the enemy
and what scares me is i got out of egypt
just before they started just gunning
down the muslim brotherhood
so you had uh you know this is 2013 you
had the second revolution in a year
and the problem was the muslim muslim
brotherhood was the largest voting bloc
so they kept they were going to win the
election but it was creating instability
because
most of the country was to a certain
degree secular
and didn't want to vote for this one
faction so a minority faction winning
elections was creating this instability
so the military said here's the answer
kill him and that's what happened so if
we're really entering this period
this freaks me out because other people
have brought up stuff like this and i
hate to even
you know kind of talk about this stuff
but if we're at the point
where you have different sides vying for
the attention going out there protesting
escalating
street battles already over the past
several years between the warring tribes
not the most
like you know insane in terms of things
i've seen and would have had in other
countries but yes still death
still some pretty shocking and extreme
scenarios trump supporter getting shot
in the chest walking down the street
twice by this dude and the law
enforcement goes and kills this guy
we're going to that point my fear is if
this instability doesn't stop
do we come to a point where those in
power just say
gun those people down get rid of those
people that's the wrong tribe whoever's
in power takes it
no you can never stop the instability
and the only way that you could is if
they became a totalitarian dictatorship
that shoved us inside and said that's no
more instability but that's why i'm
saying
they'll always be installed but they'll
go for the guns before
they start shooting themselves yeah
that's the only course that makes sense
it's really interesting to hear from uh
one of the common talking points from
the left on guns is
that you can't go up against the u.s
military they have nukes
and cruise missiles and fighter jets
it's amazing because they've never heard
of vietnam or afghanistan
so the government really does have to go
after guns before they can do
anything to lock down the people or be
totalitarian and you can 3d print guns
now so
yeah it's kind of like if you have a
like a like a cnc machine or
you know don't they have metal 3d
printers even definitely
you can you can be manufacturing all
this stuff very easily and cheaply now a
lot of people can
not only that but there's the the what's
what's the gun that can shoot one time
before it breaks
the ghost gun there's there's a plastic
gun that can take one round then it goes
together
fires and then breaks interesting
because if it breaks but a lot of them
do break easily
yeah 3d printing is not as advanced as
people think it is a lot of liberals
think
that you could just click print and get
a fully automatic machine gun that's
not how it works they thought glocks
would not be able to be detected by
metal detectors
because they don't understand what gun
parts are exactly so they really there's
some guns that are made with you know
plastic but again they don't last that
long they are
very difficult to make you can make
certain components for it but
making a full firing firearm is very
very difficult with 3d printing to be
completely honest with you
uh but i we're kind of jumbled a little
bit but i wanted to get your perspective
do you think that's a fair kind of
analysis
of of the vietnam reference when it
comes to the united states especially in
our current
kind of political crisis do you think
there could be a similar kind of
um conflict
it's possible you wouldn't have said
that again
you know four years ago that that would
have
you know i think back it was october of
2019 when the washington post came out
and
uh did an interview viewed the
the ranch um you know
the very things that we talked about i
don't mean that like i told you so in
any scenario like that because this is
just what we do this is what we pay
attention
but civil unrest we talked about
epidemics we we talked about all these
things
that are going on uh in
when the article comes out you know the
the hatred underneath all the remarks
and things people
just had could not believe that that
could possibly happen even then
and now we're two steps past that
now we're going to have a financial
reckoning yeah that's what i was going
to bring up because i was going to say
we were just talking about
politically and there's a big chance
that something like a new kind of
popular occupy wall street could happen
there's a chance of that but the more
likelihood kind of scenario is economic
that a lot of people aren't really
looking at that i think is the huge kind
of tsunami
that we're still not seeing the
ramifications it's the cascading effect
so we
to us to reach that point it's going to
it's going to be continued
lockdowns and or different variants will
come out of covet as we're already
starting to see in the news
which continues this it's this long
process that wears people out
and then the you know the straw the
bricks the camel's back will be
coming for people's guns it's a perfect
time for me to bring up i pulled up the
washington post article
and there's a perfect quote for what you
just said from this is from
drew miller quote you know people use
the term civil war
and that seems hard to imagine but what
started world war one
some guy assassinated a minor archduke
stuff escalates unpredictably yep
that's it the straw that breaks the
camel back you don't know what it's
going to be or when or how
if you're getting it oh sorry no no no
no no no no it's the liberator was that
gun you were thinking of it's a one-shot
3d printable pistol
and a ghost gun is a gun it's full
plastic
i think the entire thing was i don't
know to be honest um they printed it it
was like one of the first guns they ever
3d printed in 2013.
and it shoots once and then it breaks a
ghost gun breaks but i think
uh it's it it doesn't have that many
rounds that you could shoot with it yeah
yeah this
calls it a one-shot pistol yeah yeah you
have to reload that's what you put one
in and it fires
and they did break a lot in the early
days it was like you had to pull the
trigger with like a
with a string from far away because it
could explode in your hand so you're not
reliable
and a ghost gun is a gun that's printed
without a serial number
yeah right there's probably is that is
that legal no i don't think no you're
supposed to know
yeah you can't do that but was the
american revolution legal
well no that dude um what what was that
guy's name in in
in was it tacoma or olympia whatever who
showed up at the ice facility
yeah he had a ghost gun yeah he he made
a weapon and he showed up and was
firebombing
and it's it's all been this
cycle of of gradual escalation that i
think a lot of it
comes from the media a lot of the
tensions the the people being inflamed
crazy it's it's not just the mainstream
media though it's social media
like look at this this clip from uh from
uh you know this guy drew what's his
name pull that brett weinstein thing
back up
um don winslow this this this
what is this let me see what he's got 22
000 retweets
3.8 million views 3.8 million views
these people are being radicalized
by some random dude well is he random
let's see how many followers he's got a
verified account he's got 636 000
followers
these people are psychotic i'm sorry man
i i i
repeatedly on all of my segments say you
don't want this tone it down
stop doing this stop saying these things
and what do they do they make more
videos they ramp it up they go crazy
like i said man if you follow all these
q anon people and these conspiracy
things i think it's nuts
but what are they complaining about
global elites the one percent the
bankers the politicians
there are some issues with that for sure
you know some people get their lives
threatened and that's not a good thing
and there have been politicians people
tried to kill it's terrible
but these people are making videos
targeting regular americans
just because they're wearing a red hat
or waving a gadsden flag that kind of
amping up is coming mostly from the left
and it's going to result in more
extremism in the and the targeting of
regular people and i've seen it
i remember in i think it was 2015 i
watched an elderly couple
get shoved to the ground their hats
ripped off and set on fire i've seen
regular people just walking on the
street get punched because they
thought the person was a trump supporter
all this has been piling up
and that's why i've been saying for some
time that i think we're headed towards
whatever you want to call it i don't
know civil war would you like to say
that
maybe maybe drew is more correct when he
said
things escalate unpredictably we don't
know what when or how
you know we'll be that main catalyst
that shot heard around the world
no idea hopefully uh
it doesn't go that far no and you know
circling back to what we were talking
about even about that five percent you
know chance that something
you know can escalate and and that could
actually happen
the idea is that's not happening
tomorrow there's things that are going
to have to take place you know when i
say before
right you know calm down folks it's not
going to happen
tomorrow but it could happen tomorrow
well we'll be struck by a meteor
tomorrow no we've got 25
000 national guard in dc right now
worried
because of a threat of armed militia
groups
occupying the capital there have been
literal statements
from individuals not prominent
individuals there was one guy got
arrested for leaving a voicemail saying
he's not i don't want to repeat what he
said but he threatened
to go down and and do some crazy stuff
with people
and and they arrested the guy right but
so in order for what we're talking about
to happen
something has to be organized this again
there still has to be
there are things that need to take place
i truly believe we're heading down that
path
and depending on what our politicians do
it will direct that path one way or
another
but then you throw in the media
jumping all over it it doesn't even have
to be just for political reasons it's
sometimes it's just about money
and it's just about the influence and
the power that's gained over
that uh you know there's there's so many
factors
but it's definitely building for sure
when you have
democrats look you had ted cruz and a
variety of
some other individuals calling for unity
and the response from ocasio-cortez was
no resign now or be expelled
so if if the if the established
republicans are like chill
we'll we'll unify and the democrats say
no
and don't get me wrong you had democrats
after the election saying republicans
let's unify republicans said no
so it's really just like incongruity
neither side is willing to back down
and now that the media has been shoving
this capital right in everyone's faces
it's crazy there's a video of a guy in a
maga hat walking up to cops
and saying why aren't you doing anything
call for a backup this is the capital
call for backup trying to stop what was
going on
i saw this on reddit and the comments
were whoa a sane trump supporter that's
crazy
when you see comments like that that
this idea that
every single trump supporter is is a
[ __ ] or psychotic or a cue conspiracy
theorist
that's leading to this conflict it means
that you're reading too much reddit
no it means that you've got genkuger of
the young turks doing an op-ed for the
hill
where he said you have three factions
the leftists the the establishment
and the right-wing conspiracy nut jobs
who are all stupid and believe fake news
and i'm like i wouldn't even say that
about the left i'll say there are
prominent figures that are driving this
that are escalating it
but i i try to separate the
establishment from leftists because
there are leftists
who i think are good people and i think
you know i disagree with or have bad
ideas that's about it
and that's that's like the old saying
you know conservatives think that
liberals are misguided liberals think
conservatives are evil
when you have videos like this saying
they're all evil it's just gonna
it's gonna get crazy but i i don't know
man you know
a lot of people like to say that it's
it's something the left has no idea what
they're getting themselves into because
conservatives are more likely to be
armed and prepared and know what's going
on
but i'm not entirely convinced it would
be so one-sided
i think if there really was some kind of
conflict it's probably going to be urban
versus rural
that's like a big driving factor for
whatever reason different cultures
and there's going to be things that
people on one side or the side don't
control or don't have and it'll make
things very difficult for everybody
which is why
anybody who talks big on this stuff and
wants to happen has i i think there's no
idea what they're talking about yeah
they're clueless there are some people
who have emailed me saying
you know because i've said this over and
over again you know people who really
want this have no idea what combat and
conflict is really like
and i've gotten emails from people
saying that they served in the army or
the marines
or you know they've been overseas in
conflict and know exactly what they're
talking about
there are people who are staunch you
know believers in traditional america
and and the constitution and all of this
stuff
and they're ready and willing and angry
and they and there are some people who
who know exactly what it means
and that's freaky i think the problem is
then you're the left which is the
opposite factor
and they're just angry and they don't
know what they're asking for so the
ignorance is driving them
yeah you have a you definitely have a a
combination
um that is gonna
again i i always go back to what what
the politicians do with this right
it's not like they're unaware and so
what what happens to either fuel we know
what the media is going to do they're
just going to fuel it that's
they're in the business to do that
whatever side you're on
that's how you make money but look at
look at someone like ocasio-cortez
in order to make money for in donations
she does the exact same thing
she ramps up the escalation the tensions
she snap back clap
clap backs at the republicans always the
republicans of the worst they're always
bad
right because she well she's vying to
get power right she's
she has not been in there that long and
so it's also a power play on her side to
again you know politics is all about
that influence
and gaining all that backing in order to
do what you
think is right to do whatever that may
be
and you know she's not there yet so
that's part of
how she's playing it thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you